I've always loved San Francisco I've
looked at San Francisco and Denver both
as cities if I ever left New York where
would I go those are great cities it's
interesting though when you go there
particularly San Francisco and you see
what's going on in California today
there are a lot of people in California
and in San Francisco want to get out of
there because the quality of life and
the costs of operating and living there
and gotten so extraordinary I mean we
you know the budget deficit and what's
going on there is obvious you know we
can learn things from San Francisco's
well I mean looking what San Francisco
has done around the water for example on
how they use fairies and after the the
tragedy of the nineteen eighty nine
earthquake but the Embarcadero Freeway
came down and how that's we opened up
all the waterfront and reconnected the
people in the city of the waterfront and
how they use the ferry service to
tiburon in the east bay etc I think are
all great examples it's it's a it's a
spectacular city in a place on you know
if I were going to move that would be
certainly one of the ones i consider
Mountains you know the the the Rocky
Mountains and the natural component of
that the skiing the things you can do in
the summer it's just it's a great place
I went to college there it's just that
you need the diversity of the economy in
denver's is not what it is in New York
obviously or even when it is in San
Francisco but it's a great city and it's
a great place great people so on another
great place there are lots of great
cities in this you know in the country I
grew up in LA probably doesn't register
quite as high to me today as it did but
you know they're great places
I you know I guess my favorite spot of
Central Park there's so much going on
there all the time that's such a kind of
a melting pot of all different people
there's always stuff that's happening
it's I you know I live nearby so it's
easy to get there but to think about
what Central Park was like back in the
70s and 80s it was not it was not a
hospitable place it's not the place you
wanted to go you never go in there when
it was dark but now it's it's it's
terrific and I think you know what the
public sectors done what the private
sectors done with the Central Park
Conservancy in other parts to really
energize and program it it's a it's just
a spectacular resource for New York City
and there's so many different things to
do and I run through there not every day
but often and you know probably a bit of
a creature of habit but every time I run
through there's there's still new stuff
that I haven't seen or I haven't noticed
before I just think it's a great asset
for we have in the city
well I think that well I think that when
you think about the opportunities in the
future I don't know what you wanted to
find is hot area per se but I think when
we look at the areas where we're going
to see growth I think it's not going to
be in midtown Manhattan it's already
enough going on here you know other than
what's going on in the future and Hudson
Yards i think other really hot areas are
brooklyn williamsburg Greenpoint
williamsburg Long Island City you know I
think both of those areas have seen a
lot of investment and a lot of activity
and I really think they're poised for
significant growth going forward it's
the trendy place for people to live
folks like you going to want to live
there there's lots of restaurants
there's plenty of things to do it's
priced a little differently than other
parts of the city so I think those are
the hot trendy areas here but I think
that you know you look at Staten Island
Staten Island's got some really
competitive advantages there as well in
terms of the land that they have and
it's a more suburban type of an
environment which is I think very
attractive to people to particularly be
that proximate to to Manhattan but the
other borough that I think has got
tremendous potential and we've seen a
huge change is what's taking place in
the bronx it's been over a billion and a
half dollars of private investment
that's been made there in terms of what
the Yankees and the Steinbrenner family
deal to build did to build the new
Yankee Stadium the world champion
yankees other things with gateway center
and other developments because the Bronx
has got you know it's the it's the
poorest congressional congressional
district in the country so there's a lot
of things that can take place so we've
had huge success there with affordable
housing and I think that the the Bronx
is also you know well poised to going
forward I don't think it's in the same
time frame it's not exactly the same
place where I described long in the city
of downtown Brooklyn but I think when
you look at these different areas it's a
lot of it's going to be focused around
transportation so you have you know you
have terrific mass transit access in
downtown Brooklyn you've got terrific
past transit access in Long Island City
you've got great mass transit access up
in Harlem on 120 fifth Street
so in in the Bronx as well so were you I
think those hot areas are going to be
defined by where the real commune oh the
best transportation networks are that's
what we're trying to concentrate
activity for growth going forward in the
same